okay thanks again to the organizers for
inviting me it's certainly much more
pleasant to spend a couple of weeks in
sunny California than back in South Bend
dealing with several feet of snow so
this talk is on spacial coupling I think
it's it's it looks like it's maybe the
only talk in the workshop that's
completely on spatial coupling I mean
Tom and and aundrea both discussed
kind of a briefly a higher level view of
space but the spatial coupling from the
point of view of exit charts and G exit
charts and and I think there's a talk on
Friday floor on I think is has something
on spatial coupling in your talk but
this this talk is pretty much completely
on spatial coupling is these are the
people the guys that do all the work and
I'm the ones that get and the one that
gets to come to California give the talk
and and you know most some you know
those all those people so I'm just going
to give a brief run-through of LDPC
block codes from the point of view of
background spatially coupled LDPC codes
again a little on the brief side and
we'll concentrate more here on these
considerations this is compared to what
Tom and aundrea talked I talked about
this this could be considered more of a
nuts and bolts type of talk okay and
primarily in the third part here and and
I titled it a comparison okay I left the
word fair out it's very not so well you
know this picture okay we've got an H
matrix describes an LDPC code although
you can't really get an LDPC code on a
small screen like this but can't put too
many ones in it but it's described by a
graph and of course it has this is a JK
regular code has a certain rate
associated with it and of course we can
use low complexity belief propagation
iterative decoding for codes of this
type now one of the things that's
interesting with regard to in Sambas of
codes is the minimum distance property
so
regular LDPC block codes do they have
the property that they're asymptotically
good in Sambas in the sense that the
minimum distance grows linearly with
block lengths so in particular that
means that that there's a a typical
minimum distance ratio or a minimum
distance growth rate which depends on
the the degree profile of the regular
code the J and K with which the minimum
distance grows linearly with them and of
course there's a penalty to be paid in
terms of distance for the for the lower
for the low-density the easy encoding
and you can see compared to the gilbert
varshanov bound here's the penalty that
gets paid and that the the the sparse or
the code is the more of the penalty you
pay in distance and the the the more
dense codes get closer and closer to
optimum codes in terms of distance I
guess I said that so now thresholds of
JK regular LDPC block code in samba so
the here's a little table of B EC
thresholds I'm just going to comment on
the rate one half ones on top here and
corresponding Gaussian thresholds and a
couple of things to notice with JK
regular in Sambas is that there is a
significant gap to capacity whether you
look at the B EC or the additive white
Gaussian noise channel and also that as
you increase the density which you'd
like to do and principal if if you want
to get more distance say for example
you're you're gonna get worse compared
to capacity in both cases so that's just
a something that we have to deal with
with JK regular block codes now I'm
gonna just briefly talk about Pro to
graph representations because most of
the work we've done in and the way I'll
explain spatially coupled codes is from
the point of view of protists
so a Protagoras representation is this
is a compact representation we can start
if we like with a so-called base matrix
in just a small parity check matrix of a
of a block code and it has an Associated
Tanner graph associated with it since
it's a small base matrix it's a small
graph we call it a proto graph and of
course this goes back to Thorpe about
ten years back and then we can use a
lifting process to generate a large H
matrix by replacing nonzero elements in
the base matrix with permutation
matrices here in the larger matrix and
if and if you can have integers greater
than one here it's just the multi-edge
type construction in which you get sums
of permutation matrices up here and you
get the multiple edges down here in the
corresponding Tanner graph so every
member of a protist in samba lo does
when you use this lifting procedure
preserves the structure of the base
protocol I density evolution to the
protocols the iterative decoding
thresholds which is nice so you can you
can create in Sowell's like this and you
know their thresholds by computing them
on the on the pro two graph and also
from the protocol determine average and
Sowell weighted numerators which allows
you to determine the distance properties
in particular if you happen to have an
asymptotically good ensemble now one of
the so so I didn't mention irregular
codes here but it irregular the the
spatially coupled codes in some sense
that can be viewed as trying to combine
the best properties of regular codes and
irregular codes the regular codes as we
saw you can get they're asymptotically
good in terms of distance the irregular
codes of course can do much better in
terms of thresholds so the spatially
coupled codes we can consider it this
way here's a base matrix with the
corresponding protis is of a multi edged
type is just one way of representing a
three six regular block code and we
consider transmission of code words
successively from drawing code words
drawn from this this ensemble now we can
then we can change things by spatially
coupling just introducing memory between
consecutive prota graphs here and one
way of talking about this is we can so
call spread the edges over time
otherwise we can take this graph and
spread these three edges over say the
next two time units and the next two
parity-check symbols in this graph and
that's equivalent to taking this base
matrix B and splitting it up into three
in this example three individual sub
matrices b0 b1 and b2 all of the same
size and there's a so-called memory
associated with this edge spreading of
two which means we've we've taken edges
from here and jumped over to prote
aggress are connected over two to prout
aggress so the the there's different
edge spreading that can be used and
sometimes they can result even for the
same base matrix they can result in
different properties different
Azzam time distance properties different
threshold properties okay so the
graphically then if you put the whole
thing together a spatially coupled
Tanner graph results in what we could
also call a convolutional prota graph
because the the coupling and the
introducing of mem the introduction of
Mamre between these successive block
prota graphs really makes the block code
into a convolutional code and we get a
so-called convolutional program and that
has a so-called by infinite in this case
since we're not talking about any kind
of termination yet convolutional base
matrix which has the the familiar
diagonal form of the parity check matrix
of a convolutional code
and it has a rate associated with it
these parameters go back to the
parameters of the base matrix that we
started with that we that we coupled and
as a convolutional code it as a
constraint length associated with it
which is basically just the number of
symbols the the the other parts of the
of the base matrix here are are all 0 so
the the number of symbols the number of
columns in the non 0 portion of this
diagonal would be the constraint length
and of course this this is still a base
matrix and this just gets lifted in the
same way that the base matrix of block
codes gets lifted we these are the these
are the the sub matrices when we did the
edge spreading and wherever we have 1s
or nonzero symbols we put in large
permutation matrices to create an in
sambala spatially couple of this song
now of course terminating spatially
coupled codes we always have some
starting point and then we can also
terminate at the end by just doing this
just chopping it off at the end of one
particular column and there's a rate
loss associated with termination where L
is kind of the termination length but
for large L if you terminate after a so
this is a large number of program
sections the the terminated code rate
approaches the original design Pro to
great design rate of the original
program if you want okay so for example
if we take this three six example with
this base matrix that we have a a memory
of two so we spread the edges over two
adjacent sections of very small L here
a4 otherwise they couldn't get it on one
page
the the rate here this is a the design
rate is 1/2 this is all the way down to
a quarter for the ShoreTel but this is
what the convolutional base matrix would
look like and this is what the
corresponding Tanner graph would look
like and the key thing to notice here is
that even though this is this is based
a regular block code and maintains in to
large extent expecially for large L that
same regular structure the check nodes
at the ends have lower degrees otherwise
the check nodes in the middle all have
degree six but the the the two at this
and one of them as degree for one of
them as degree two and same at this end
so these are stronger local constraints
at the ends of the convolutional prota
graph which is crucial in allowing us in
in in giving us the improved thresholds
of these types of constructions so these
can be I think I said this but they get
lifting can be used you can vary the
lifting factor and they and the
termination length to get insomnia
okay and those so there's a there's a so
called wave-like encoding as I mentioned
all the variable notes here all going to
have the same degree as the underlying
block codes the check nodes also the
same degree except at the ends and
that's what improves the belief
propagation decoding a little picture
this is B EC channels this is just time
these are numbers of iterations as we go
to the the right here and this is this
is kind of after ten iterations and you
can see the error rate in the beginning
there in the middle here is 50% but
things have improved a little bit at the
ends here after ten iterations because
of these strong local codes at the end
coming from the low-degree checks and as
we do more iterations twenty fifty a
hundred so we see the the improved
performance propagating towards the
middle from both ends which which is the
so-called wave-like decoding associated
with spatially coupled codes so
eventually everything gets good so the
and and the thing that is important to
realize to this the diffraction of these
lower degree nodes at the ends which
gives us this nice feature really goes
to zero as L goes to infinity so the cut
we sometimes refer to these as
asymptotically regular codes are almost
regular code so the idea is we're trying
to preserve the the the regular
structure so we get distance and yet
also get the threshold performance of
more often associated with irregular
codes so we can do density evolution as
I said on the protocols and this is an
example for B EC so here is the Shannon
limit for rate 1/2 on the B EC which is
1/2 the the this is the
this is the Shannon limit for the other
rates associated when remember as we
vary L we change the rate changes it
starts out at a low rate so at the low
rates like L equal for the Shannon limit
is 0.75 and our spatially coupled limit
has a gap there it's only 0.6 3 5 & 4 L
equal 10 and our rate our rate is up to
our rate is up to 0.4 the Shannon limits
at point 6 and we're a little closer to
the Shannon limit in that case and this
this continues to the point where these
are the spatially coupled thresholds
which come to point four eight eight
very close to the Shannon limit those of
you that know this know that this is the
map threshold actually even though we're
still doing you know we're still basing
this on belief propagation whereas the
three six regular block code that we
started with has this point four three
threshold associated with us so we get
to step up and threshold very close to
the Shannon limit and actually at the at
the map threshold so looking back at a
table like this so iterative decoding
thresholds for spatially coupled codes
so we have we have significant
improvements relative to the
corresponding block code thresholds the
block code thresholds of the
corresponding regular codes erasure
channel Gaussian channel and what's
really different here and noticeable is
that the as the density increases here
the thresholds increase rather than get
worse as they did in the block code case
which gives us improving thresholds and
improving distance properties as we
improve as we increase the density so
another way of looking at this is that
you know this is again BSD
you see once you know symbols perfectly
you can kind of remove them and the
graph kind of collapses to the middle so
this this threshold saturation was
observed there was numerical work in
this paper showing that they're
indistinguishable for map thresholds SL
goes to infinity and then proofs
forgiven analytically in a couple of
more recent papers both for the B EC and
then more recently for more general
channels that the so called threshold
saturation effect so another way of
viewing this this is let me start here
so this is the this is block codes and
we see here this is again a ratio
channel map threshold BP threshold
simulated performance I can't remember
the block length it was pretty big and
you see as we go from three six two five
ten the block code performance follows
the BP threshold okay and and gets worse
because the BP thresholds are worse the
map thresholds get better okay with
increasing density and since the the
spatially coupled codes followed the
even though we're using belief
propagation decoding they follow the map
thresholds so the three six is here
close to the map threshold the five ten
is even better
it moves with the map thresholds how big
do you have to have it so that you
actually
well big I mean III this this I'm trying
to remember what 100 100k maybe I don't
know what would you say Rudy I did get
really yeah yeah yeah you need the
length per Section okay give me that B
there's a final thing to get associates
with that which is this so scary what I
was great law yeah
and then you need the rate close to be
reasonably small I think these might
have been I don't remember 60,000
so be ICI now so here we just plotting
so these are the thresholds now again
there's a there's a curve of thresholds
associated with each this would be the
three six curve because the short
termination lengths have very low rates
and then the thresholds are not so close
to the Shannon limit until they get up
until L gets very large okay and we can
see with the 510 you can see that it
actually gets there and these are
distance results this is the spate again
the spatially coupled codes have a range
of rates associated with them as
depending on the termination and the
debt they're asymptotically good and now
these are the these are the minimum
distance properties of the underlying
block codes so these are the min
distances of the Associated spatially
couple codes depending on the rate they
stay as emphatically good the distance
though goes towards zero is the
termination length goes large gets large
and similar results can be obtained for
the Gaussian trail obviously this is the
same curve because it's a distance curve
one point I like I want to make though
is I I don't with spatially coupled
codes
I don't think minimum distance is the
right way to measure the strength of
these codes in terms of you know like
arrow for performance well obviously
there's trapping sets and observing sets
and things of this nature or just in
terms of distance because I think it's
clear if you think about it the
performance of these codes is not going
to get worse just by increasing the
termination length
these are convolutional type codes so
it's more of the free distance of the
underlying unterminated convolutional
code that i think is we don't have any
firm results on this but we do have we
do have bounds on the free distance and
the free distance the constraint length
ratio does not depend on L and stays
constant and it's reasonable to say that
an appropriate distance measure for
these convolutional like ensembles
should be independent of L
okay unlike the minimum distance ones
what you're getting worse as L gets
larger so there's something we want to
investigate further
so some practical considerations so
spatially coupled code again you can
look at just the decoding is coming from
both ends like this
towards the middle like we showed with
that wave-like picture but that the
highly localized the convolutional
structure makes it easy to do using
decoding schedules that reduce memory
and particularly both memory and latency
requirements so a sliding window which
actually let my are used in to do to
actually do density evolution analysis
of these codes and then Paul student
Arvind actually was the first to propose
using a sliding window actually for
decoding okay so the sliding window
decoder works like this and if we
compare performance so this is these two
this is for a block code with a lifting
factor of a thousand these are all three
sixes this is a convolutional code
especially coupled code lifting factor
of a thousand I was in to bite my tongue
whether I'm going to say convolution
spatially coupled with different with
different lifting factors and different
window sizes so with the same lifting
factor we get quite a gain with the
spatially coupled code it's not really
fair because if you compare the
latencies because of the window size the
spatially coupled codes going to have a
larger latency but if you do it on an
equal latency basis so you would make
the window size then or the lifting
factor smaller depending on the window
size you're using so that the latencies
are the same you still get a gain a
couple tenths of a DB and you can play
with the lifting factor in the window
size to try to get as much gain as you
can for the spatially coupled code
there's this is kind of flexibility
that's not built into
to the block code now I won't say
anything much about finite lane scaling
this is just some results from Pablo and
Rudy's paper just showing that the
analysis does match simulations very
well I think Rudy talked about this
comparison the other day and his his
brief presentation but just the
comparison of the scaling behavior of
spatially coupled codes compared to
polar codes is better with regard to
LDPC codes which would just be block
codes here not as good but it the
comparison is is uncertain because the
block code comparison is with threshold
and here we're comparing with there are
the results there compared with capacity
okay what about this goes back to equal
latency again and this this picture
shows the required signal noise ratio
this Gaussian channel simulations needed
to get a certain latency and you can see
that so the the block code curve is the
black curve and these are the these are
the lifting factors associated these
spatially coupled curves are different
colors and they all have different
lifting factors in different window
sizes again there's this trade-off and
we kind of see so these are the blue is
the smallest lifting factor and then the
other curves that the the lifting factor
and and window size are adjusted so the
latency is whatever it says here on the
x-axis and we kind of see again that we
have several tenths of a DB advantage
with the spatially coupled codes as long
as we're talking latency larger than
something okay in each case the block
code will win at smaller Layton sees but
at larger Layton sees the spatially
couple codes will perform better just in
general in looking at these parameters
this trade-off between lifting factor
and window size the large lifting factor
will improve code before
the large window size will be improve
the decoder performance
these are complexity trade-offs now it's
just note updates we just counted note
updates and the these are four different
latencies are different lifting factors
and basically you can see here this
includes non binary so this is a block
code curve here and let's just take one
for comparison this is a spatially
coupled code curve here so you can see
the spatially coupled code does does pay
some penalty in complexity which grows
with field size I mean here's the
comparison down here for binary okay
this is for equal latency but the the
spatially couple of coats of course have
a performance gain and one thing to
point out and this is with stopping
rules both codes were decoded with
stopping rules one thing to point out is
you could give the block code more
iteration say but it's never gonna make
up the performance gap okay so the
performance gap is there it takes a
little more computation to get it with
this spatially coupled code but for this
latency the block code will not be able
to get there this is a funny crap again
so we're fixing performance ten to the
minus five bit error rate at 1.5 DB and
replying latency versus computational
complexity so how do I want to try to
show this okay let's take binary this is
the block code and this is a spatially
coupled code so same performance now so
the spatially coupled code gets the same
performance with more than a factor of
two less and latency a little bit more
computation same thing more or less with
for Airy a big improvement in latency
more than a factor of three here these
are based on random codes and you could
argue about how
you know if you did this or that or
something but I think they're
representative I think again a big
improvement in latency but just as wit
for a cost of only a small increase in
complete complexity good trade-off here
we go to a Terry it's the same type of
picture block and spatially coupled but
notice to get a little imp little less
latency you're paying a lot in
complexity in both cases within in fact
here you're with a block you're going
backwards you're worse in complexity and
in latency so it seems like gf4 may be a
sweet spot where you get a good balance
between complexity and latency and for
the same performance you get a an
improvement now we did it we did I'm
running out of time we did a comparison
with irregular codes okay we cuz that's
the other thing well you're always
comparing with regular what about
well-designed ear regulars the the the
basic thing we took an irregular which
had roughly the same rate in the same
threshold as our spatially coupled code
and what do we expect well the spatially
coupled code is based on a regular
structure which the irregular code
doesn't have so the spatially coupled
coach somehow should do better in terms
of error floors we we expect or we hope
and this is at least the preliminary
simulations we've done this is the
spatially coupled code and this is the
irregular code and we allowed a maximum
of 100 iterations here and only ten here
because we have a window of eight so the
computation complexity is roughly
equivalent here because we have a
shifting window so those those
comparisons look reasonable they also
look good compared to irregular codes
you haven't done a lot of these this has
to do with random puncturing and then of
course these last couple of slides just
say that you can also spatially couple
their regular codes
these are argit codes vary
good irregular codes with that are
asymptotically good and they can
spatially couple those also so hardware
advantages so you know would there be
advantages with quasi cyclic designs we
have this asymptotically regular
structure we have a flexible frame
length feature by very an L and flexible
rate feature by puncturing and of course
there's ongoing work and looking at
stopping sets trapping sets and
absorbing sets with regard to error for
this facially coupled in Samba was a
chief threshold saturation thresholds
approach the Mapp thresholds of the
underlying block code in Sowell's they
combined I think this is the key thing
maybe the best features of JK regular
and irregular block codes are kind of
combined with spatially coupled codes
and with window decoding they also
perform they compare well with block
codes in the finite length regime in
terms of equal latency and complexity
tag so thank you I'm sorry I took a
couple extra money